foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if there's one thing Nintendo has become
increasingly efficient at it's their
ability to obscure lore and story
details in their Zelda trailers they
show just enough to get people talking
while at the same time preserving a high
degree of ambiguity to keep us guessing
it's no exaggeration to say that we
could easily have a two-hour discussion
on just who this one character is
supposed to be is it hylia an ancient
hero a Ganondorf tingle
or judging by Nintendo's track record it
could be a completely new character one
we've never seen before and so all our
theories go out the window no matter how
confident you are in your own assessment
it's safe to say that for now all we
have is best guesses as the characters
depicted are purposely designed in a way
that makes them unlike anything we can
immediately recognize from previous
titles I've been staring at screenshots
for hours and while I do have my own
ideas and suspicions so far I've been
unable to find substantial evidence that
Nails it down so for today's video let's
put this part of the lore aside for a
moment and focus on something else a far
more important question perhaps why do
bakoblins and marblin suddenly have
massive penis
today we're talking about the surface
world of Tears of the Kingdom which as
we all know is basically a rehash of the
landscape we explored in the previous
title pry's tears of the Kingdom's main
focus ever since the 2021 teaser has
been on the skies above the ill-fated
Kingdom which is now littered with these
Majestic floating land masses that have
seemingly sprung up from nowhere even
the official artwork including the box
art emphasized that in tears of the
Kingdom the sky is where it's at there's
been a couple of video analysis which
focus on the differences between breath
of the Wild's Overworld and the one seen
in tears of the Kingdom in conclusion
well aside from a few notable changes to
specific landmarks the two aren't all
that different almost identical even so
what purpose does the surface have left
and besides providing solid footing when
you're not soaring in the skies above of
course it is from ground level that will
be gaining access to some of the islands
as seen in the example where link
rewinds a piece of Fallen Sky debris and
rides it up to the island it originated
from but this is just a means by which
to escape the surface so what about
Hyrule itself are there new things to
explore here new Dungeons and challenges
nine thousand korok seats this time no
God please no no
I think there may be a lot more to
Hyrule surface than the promotional
material has led on so far though it may
look very similar from a distance you
can't judge a book by its cover so let's
go over some of the possibilities do
keep in mind that just like with the
main story most of what I'm about to
talk about is highly speculative and may
not reflect the final product in fact it
probably won't with that said let's get
into it in the footage presented so far
tears of the Kingdom's surface has been
shown quite sparingly and when it does
show up it's in specific lighting and
from clever camera angles that make it
difficult to see the finer details
despite this we have been able to spot a
few changes over the past years ever
since the game's review in 2019 the most
notable of which are that the shika
towers and shrines are no longer present
Hyrule Castle has been ripped from its
foundation and is now suspended in the
air by ganon's malice the Deku Tree and
possibly the entire great Forest are no
longer where they should be there are
strange pieces of debris scattered about
which weren't there before and death
Mountain's lava flow has seemingly run
dry the mystery behind the last two of
these observations have now been cleared
up by the Third teaser the unknown
debris is confirmed to originate from
the floating islands and as mentioned
before you can use them to hitch a ride
up Death Mountain has dried up because
it's plugged up by malice which can be
seen boiling up from the summit but
there's another big change which a lot
of people initially missed for good
reason because it's not actually shown
in the teaser itself but instead in the
official artwork Nintendo made public
shortly after the teaser went live here
too we see the malice written Death
Mountain the floating Hyrule castle and
another peculiar site a gigantic Vortex
covering a large area west of the castle
judging from the size comparison to the
other two landmarks this storm has to be
about the same size if not bigger than
Death Mountain itself which on its own
is so massive that it almost takes up an
entire Province there's still a debate
going on in regards to which part of the
map specifically has been engulfed by
this giant storm there's been
suggestions of the hebra mountains Rito
Village the Forgotten Temple some even
think it may be as far south as Satori
Mountain I personally believe that
anything below Rito Village is
improbable if we line up the positions
in the artwork we can see that the storm
is approximately to the West maybe
slightly Northwest of the castle this
would place it somewhere in this general
area we can also see a long canyon-like
depression in the landscape between the
vortex and the castle and if I had to
guess this would have to be tanagar
Canyon the giant Gorge that spans from
the Gerudo Highlands in the South all
the way up North and separates Central
Hyrule from The hebra Province if this
is indeed tanagar Canyon this eliminates
places like Satori and the Forgotten
Temple and narrows it down to hebra
alone as it's the only province that
lies west of the canyon my top two
contenders right now are Rito Village
and the hebra peak and I'm currently
leaning more towards the ladder for a
couple of reasons primarily the fact
that we don't see hebra Peak anywhere in
the artwork which is a bit strange the
summit of hebra is one of the highest
peaks on the map only slightly
outclassed by Death Mountain and the two
even share approximately the same
latitude as well the mountain and its
iconic look that being the massive hole
carved into its Peak should stand out
quite clearly and yet it's nowhere to be
seen so it might be in the eye of the
storm this location was also severely
underutilized in breath of the wild
especially given its size and for
another reason I'll get to in a bit this
is currently my best bet I don't want to
obsess over the exact location for too
long because I do realize that
depictions of Hyrule and artworks like
these are often stylistic and not always
accurate to the actual in-game map what
is important is the tribe who called
this province home whether the vortex is
situated at hebra Peak or Rito Village
the storm has depicted in the yard work
looks big enough that it would spell
serious trouble for the Rito's way of
life regardless and may even cover both
areas after all Rito Village lies right
at the foot of the mountain range and
their training facility the flight range
lies even closer in my visual concept I
happen to choose Habra Peak mostly
because it looks cool but Rito Village
is a strong Contender as well perhaps it
lies at the eye of the storm with its
inhabitants trapped inside unable to
escape but even if the village lies at
the edge of it it would still pose a
serious problem in imagine the immense
Force as one would endure so close to a
tornado of this size the wind speeds
blizzards flying debris and the freezing
temperature of the area I doubt it would
be a pleasant experience for Our
Feathered Friends I think it's quite
interesting that a significant plot
Point like this was shown in artwork
alone there's only one very brief moment
in the footage that alludes that
something might be happening in hebra
and it's so subtle that it only works in
context knowing what we know now from
the artwork in the first few frames of
the final shot where link is in free
fall we can see a patch of dark clouds
on the left side of the screen and below
that we can see the snowy border of the
hebra province this may seem trivial I
mean it's just a few clouds but the
weather system in breath of the wild
didn't work like that you can see this
for yourself the next time you play the
game you will never see an isolated
patch of rain or thunder clouds hanging
above one specific area when the sky
changes it changes globally as far as
the eyes can see even in places that
don't match that weather condition
you'll see rain clouds above the grudo
desert only to fast travel there and
find it dry and sunny and now suddenly
the place you came from is too logically
speaking a place like fahren which is
notorious for its frequent rainfall and
thunderstorms should oftentimes have
dark clouds hanging above it when viewed
from a distance but it doesn't unless
the weather is also bad where you are I
don't know exactly how it works and I'm
getting sidetracked again but the Skybox
seems to be localized or tied to Link's
position on the map or something the
only exception to the rule are special
events that are disconnected from the
global weather system an example being
the thunderstorm hanging above Thunder
at Plateau which is always present no
matter the weather conditions or time of
day so either tears of the Kingdom has a
completely new weather system which is
possible or these dark clouds are part
of the very edge of the storm tormenting
hebra it could even be both my obsessive
talk about storms clouds and weather
aside what does it all mean for Hyrule
surface in general I mean one additional
storm is nice and all and big as it may
be it doesn't exactly make a huge
difference considering the size of the
map in its entirety so maybe this storm
is not the end of it you'll notice is
that most of the changes we've been able
to spot so far all correlate to specific
people or factions from breath of the
wild the Hylian seed of power Death
Mountain Home of the gorons the missing
Deku Tree Spirit guardian of the koroks
and now this giant storm potentially
terrorizing the Rito I don't think I'm
alone when I say that there seems to be
a pattern here these are all beings and
factions who stood against Ganon in some
way either providing support on the day
of the Calamity or 100 years after the
apocalypse when the hero woke up for a
rematch now that the true face behind
the Calamity Ganondorf himself is back
in the flesh it is to be expected that
he would Target those who foiled his
scheme to take over Hyrule these four
factions already checked the box but
there's also the Gerudo shika and the
Zora the total number of races that
stood against Ganon and currently still
inhabit Hyrule amounts to seven I'm
excluding the yiga as they are basically
just chica turned evil is it a
coincidence then that we happen to see
this god-like figure surrounded by seven
orbs many have made the connection that
the seven orbs could correspond to 7 and
dungeons with a possible eighth and
final one as Zelda games tend to have
the numbers 7 and 8 are quite prevalent
in breath of the Wild and the series as
a whole for that matter the most notable
are the seven heroine statues plus the
secret eighth heroine which is said to
have been wiped from history we have all
the imagery referencing the seven sages
the seven races of the Kingdom with the
zonai possibly being the missing eighth
not to mention breath the Wild's Hyrule
is divided into eight provinces the only
problem is we haven't seen substantial
footage of any location belonging to the
other factions there's not a single
frame of Zora's domain kakariko Village
which is barely visible in this shot is
too far away to confirm any changes and
the home of the Gerudo is obscured by
the highlands that wrap around the
entire Province so we can't say for sure
if these areas are also struck by
disaster the pattern suggests that they
probably are but right now we have no
proof of this of course the fact that we
don't see these afflictions from afar in
some of these wide charts doesn't mean
they don't exist for all we know the
Waters of zoro's domain could be
poisoned or something and the guru are
being tortured by an endless loop of the
rude Sandstorm the orbs depicted on the
mural could represent some sort of
balance or stability a balance which
could have been corrupted by Ganondorf
leading to all kinds of disasters across
hyrule's provinces and in order to cure
this imbalance link has to visit some
sort of ancient temples or shrines to
well you know how it generally goes into
other games another possibility is that
these orbs are the key to restoring the
master sword in some way which Ganondorf
is aware of and the many calamities
plaguing these regions are simply him
trying to prevent link from getting to
them if there are indeed bigger more
classic dungeons present in tears of the
Kingdom I think it's more than possible
that most if not all of them are found
on the surface or below it as opposed to
in the skies above it would give a new
and important purpose to the lands of
Hyrule it's one more reason why I chose
hebra Peak as my Prime candidate for the
eye of the storm as opposed to Rito
Village as it would be a perfect
location to house a secret Temple of
sorts we have proof that the hebra
mountains have all sorts of caves and
secret Chambers inside them some of them
hidden behind man-made doors like the
enormous cave that houses one of the
great skeletons so what about the
islands in the sky then what purpose
would they serve if dungeons end up
being on the surface below well it could
be that the means to access these
ancient temples are obtained here like
certain powers for Link's new bracelet
for example it's not uncommon for a
Zelda game to hide key items necessary
to gain access to a dungeon somewhere
else in the Overworld by traveling to
the sky and learning new abilities you
would be able to unlock new areas at
ground level now this may sound like it
would be an extremely linear experience
but that doesn't have to be the case at
all if you can visit the many islands in
any order you please it means that the
dungeons too can be tackled in any order
just like in breath of the wild it goes
without saying that this is all
conjecture maybe dungeons are present in
the sky maybe the surface World serves a
completely different purpose maybe these
are just stylistic depictions of a
loincloth you may have noticed while
talking about this stuff happening on
the surface that I primarily used
footage from the newest teaser as
opposed to the other two this is because
in the older footage some things we've
talked about like the storm in hebra are
different or not yet present we can see
hebra Peak right behind the castle in
this shot and yet there's nothing
unusual about it while it could be that
this takes place earlier in the story
before some of these cataclysms manifest
it's also obvious that Nintendo is
constantly adding things and making
changes to the game as they go along
Death Mountain initially didn't have
malice erupting from its Summit the
bottom of the floating islands used to
look like natural rock formations while
in the recent footage most of them have
these man-made antennas all of a sudden
and there are many more examples of
changes and things being moved around as
development progresses which is only
natural I mean think back at how
different breath of the wild looked in
some of the early footage all we can do
is guess which is a big part of the fun
of anticipation at least for me and
there's so much more to theorize about
by the looks of it tears of the Kingdom
as one of the broadest set of goals and
Mysteries in any Zelda game to date the
broken Master Sword the curse on Link's
arm Zelda's disappearance and if and how
we'll get her back the catastrophe is
inflicted on Hiro's people the mystery
and Legacy of the zonai so on and so
forth anyway that is all for today a big
shout out to my mods Discord Community
everyone who's been sharing ideas and
theories with me in the past week or so
and of course my patreons and channel
members of which William Charles and Sam
T joined recently so a big thanks to the
both of you it means a lot I have plenty
of ideas to work with in the coming
weeks so I hope you look forward to
future videos this is Don signing off
and have a good one
[Music]
foreign thank you
[Music]